Ja, oder auch nicht.
Semi-Death am Start.
Moin.
SargenSilver war zuerst da.
Sehr gut.
Man, erstmal wieder ein bisschen
wach werden.
Ich hab nicht gepennt oder so, aber
wie nennt man es so schön heute?
Gechillt.
Bei heute sagt man das wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr.
Gechillt, das war ja schon fast
mein Jahrgang, der das
gesagt hat. Was sagt man denn heute dazu?
Max ans Trinken erinnern.
Das ist eine gute Idee. Hab ich grad gemacht.
Auflock!
Was soll denn das
bedeuten?
Was soll das heißen?
Heute wird im Kreis
der Mindset nicht mehr gechillt.
Wo ist das?
Die sind doch alle in der Gruppe.
Irgendwas mit locker entspannt.
Ich
glaube nicht, dass das was
damit zu tun hat.
Auflock!
Na gut.
Das finde ich aber ziemlich bescheuert.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Ich habe gemerkt,
in letzter Zeit,
wenn man sich so als alter Boomer
so ein bisschen umguckt,
mal so
auf teilweise
TikTok oder
das in Videos und so,
was sich so die jüngeren Leute angucken.
Mir ist aufgefallen, dass
Digger gar nicht mehr so
angesagt ist. Es sagt
gefühlt kaum noch einer
Digger.
Was sagt man denn jetzt,
wenn es nicht mehr Digger ist?
Heute sagt man Bro.
Oder Bre.
Digger ist
nicht mehr so angesagt.
Auflock!
Steht für eine alternative
Version von Auflocker.
Aha.
Operation Locker.
Das war ein Boomer Witz.
Auflocker
angenehm. Locker gemacht.
Auflock!
Okay, das ist
aber echt dumm.
Das ist aber echt dumm.
Auflock!
Etzer macht was? Jabber.ru?
Weiß nicht, ob ich die Seite
aufmachen will.
Ups.
Ich krieg das Mikrofon gekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das
prinzipiell erzählt, dass jede
Generation, ja das stimmt schon,
aber ich muss sagen, ich war doch bisher
relativ generationsübergreifend
so halbwegs im Bilde, immer durch Streaming
und YouTube und alles.
Deswegen denke ich, kann ich relativ
objektiv einschätzen.
Naja, was objektiv. Für mich,
ob ich was dumm finde oder nicht.
Und Auflock finde ich so spontan
echt dumm.
Das fand ich zum Beispiel ne
sinnvolle Sache.
Das war ein schöner, stimmiger
Begriff für
ja, um was zu bezeichnen,
was sonst schwierig zu umschreiben ist.
Ja, Suspekt ist halt
das passt richtig. Sus weiß jeder
was gemeint. Das ist so verdächtig
so ein bisschen. Nehmen wir so ein bisschen was
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Sus.
Ja, NPC, das ist sowas,
da frage ich mich schon lange, warum das nicht öfters
gesagt wird. Ja.
Also NPC
finde ich zum Beispiel richtig gut,
dass es jetzt
kommt, so als
ja halbes, ich sag kein
Schimpfwort, so als. Wobei,
das bestimmt sehr, wie soll man sagen,
sehr vielfältig eingesetzt werden
kann.
So auch um mal Leute zu dissen,
das sagt man heute bestimmt auch nicht mehr.
Also es gab bei mir echt auch viele
dumme Sachen und dumme Trends.
Eines der dümmsten Trends waren Jojos.
Heute hat niemand
mehr Jojos. Es gab mal eine Zeit, da hat
jeder so ein komisches Jojo gehabt.
Dann gab es
mal einen Trend. Kennt ihr noch diese Adidas
Hosen zum Aufknöpfen?
War auch sehr beliebt mal eine Zeit lang.
Dann gab es mal
solche, solche,
solche Chips.
Solche Chips zum
draufwerfen.
Ich habe vergessen, wie die heißen.
Tamagotchis gab es auch.
Wie hieß das noch?
Kennt das noch jemand? Es gab mal so Chips.
Also so Papierchips.
Pox
hieß das. Ganz genau.
Jetzt weiß ich es wieder.
Pox, genau.
Also es gab schon, es gab enorm
viele dumme Trends.
Ja, genau, genau.
So richtig, so richtig dumm.
Habe ich die Story, habe ich das schon mal
erzählt mit dem Metall-Slammer, oder?
So Metall, also
ausgeliefert wurde das alles
mit so einem billigen, so einem billigen
Plastikding und man konnte sich halt so einen Metall-Slammer
kaufen, hat irgendwie gefühlt halt das halbe Ding
und hat den Schulhof gefeuert.
Ja, auf Log ist
dumm. Ja, Sass ist okay. NPC
finde ich auch nicht schlecht.
Okay, wenn Sass nicht mehr aktuell ist, wie nennt man
das denn heute?
Ich finde das eigentlich, ich finde das eigentlich sehr,
ich finde Sass hat echt das Zeug so zum
langfristigen, universal,
ja nicht mal mehr reines
Jugendwort. Ja, genau,
die meine ich.
Die Adidas Schnellfickerhosen,
wie auch immer man auf diesen Namen gekommen ist,
aber die meine ich.
Ich meine diese Adidas Hosen, die heute
eigentlich nur noch die Assis irgendwo in der S-Bahn
anhaben. Und dann halt aber auch
irgendwelches super alte,
abgetragenes Zeug.
Das will ich heute nicht sehen, da habe ich heute keinen Bock drauf
auf den Gaming-Kram.
Ich mach das mal zu. Ich mach das nicht nur zu,
ich mach Package-Update
und
wir Rebooten.
Weil Arch, by the way,
Rolling Release, ja,
weg damit.
XD ist auch was, da bin ich nie
drauf klar gekommen, warum Leute XD
verwenden. Ich mach das auch manchmal,
aber dann immer, wenn ich will, dass es
besonders dumm aussieht.
Also, ich würde nie in, sag mal so,
in nem ernsthaften Chat, also
ich meine nicht, dass der Chat ernsthaft sein will,
aber nur wenn ich irgendjemand, also
XD würde ich nur schreiben, wenn ich irgendjemanden
nicht abkann, ja, und
ich dem das auch zeigen will, dass ich ihn
nicht mag. Dann würde ich
schreiben, irgendwas,
bla bla bla, XD hintendran.
Ansonsten finde ich XD einfach
richtig dumm. XD ist
richtig dumm. Gibt auch so ne Angewohnheit,
die kommt noch aus MMOs
bei mir, und das mach ich immer noch ganz gerne,
dass da
hinter, es gab ne Zeit
in MMOs, da hab ich echt
ernsthaft hinter jedem Satz hab ich
geschrieben, das sind
so japanische
Freudenaugen, so Anime
Freude, Freude, Face.
Aber das wusste ich damals gar nicht.
Das hab ich hinter jedem Satz
gefühlt gemacht.
Und was ich, was ich,
was ich auch, was ich auch gar nicht
mag, der hier,
ja, natürlich, da gibt's auch noch den da,
oder es gab dann auch Leute, die haben
irgendwie, irgendwie, nee, wie ging das andere?
Wieso? Oder gibt's
zig Varianten? Also,
also,
äh, was wollt ich jetzt sagen?
Ja, da gibt's
da gibt's jede Menge, gibt's
jede Menge. Also eine Sache, die
ich fast schon so mittlerweile als richtig
passiv-aggressiv in Chats
empfinde, ist das hier.
Ausgeschriebene
Oldschool-Emotes.
Das kann ich
überhaupt nicht ab. Das wirkt
wirklich so wie 60-jähriger
Facebook-Boomer.
Das find ich ganz schlimm.
Das hier, das hier,
okay, also, jetzt, jetzt,
jetzt war ich ernsthaft. Der normale,
der ist auch schon richtig, richtig
schlimm, ja, aber der geht noch.
Aber der hier ist echt der allerschlimmste.
Guck mal, sogar mein
Bash-Highlight, den kackt dabei ab.
Ja, verständlich.
Da heißt die Frage, ob man es mit
3 macht, mit 8 oder mit B.
Ich hab schon alles gesehen.
Also ich, ich bevorzuge die.
Die oder die. Was auch immer.
So, Reboot!
Wir machen gleich eine Runde
neue Set-Server-Challenges.
CTF darf man's ja nicht nennen, weil's ja kein
Security, nicht wirklich
irgendwelche Hacker-Mensch-Dells ist.
Ja, versteh ich auch, versteh ich auch.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, die triggern einen echt so.
Also ich mag diesen ganz alten
Smiley, der so zwinkert, nicht.
Okay, das ist ja noch schlimmer.
Das ist, das ist ja noch
schlimmer.
Wobei ich sagen muss,
nee, nee, ehrlich,
der geht besser. Das ist der Schlimmste.
Das ist wirklich der Schlimmste.
Gerade wenn da Leute irgendwie im Chat
sowas schreiben wie, hast du das
denn nicht gesehen? Und dann,
und dann dieses Ding dahinter machen. Das wirkt
so ultra-passiv-aggressiv. Man interpretiert
eh in geschriebene Sachen ultra viel rein,
obwohl das meistens nicht so gemeint ist.
Aber,
ey, das kann ich
überhaupt nicht, diesen, diesen, diesen
alten Smiley.
Das, ganz ehrlich,
Emote, äh, FiveHatMasterRace
ist eh
Twitch-Emotes zu verwenden auf Plattformen,
wo's auch kein Twitch, äh, wo's keine Twitch-Emotes
gibt. Ja.
Server abgekackt.
W. Irgendwie sowas.
Das ist dann, das, das
ist dann Peak-Emote.
Emoting.
Funktioniert leider nur mit Leuten,
die auch Durchblick haben.
Leider
zu wenige.
Aber hier sind wir richtig.
Ich muss mich ja hier noch einloggen, sehe ich gerade.
Ich mach mal kurz den Private-Tab
auf, weil ich nicht will, dass ich mir
irgendwie Passwort speichere, Passwort leake
oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Login.
Ja, Moment.
Login. Login.
Okay.
Ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen.
Chat, überlegt euch mal,
für was, für was ist
unser Stream heute besser?
In der, in der All, in der Just-Chatting-Kategorie?
Oder
in Software- und
Game-Development? Weil,
wirklich Software- und Game-Development ist es ja
eigentlich gar nicht, ne?
Meint ihr? So, ich hab das Passwort
nicht geleakt.
E-Mail-Adresse ist nicht geheim.
Hauptsache, Hauptsache nicht, Passwort
leakt. E-Mail-Adresse
ist nicht geheim, da könnt ihr mir sogar Paypal drauf
überweisen, wenn ihr wollt. Ha! Will wahrscheinlich
keiner aber.
Gelulwe.
Alternativ, wir können uns auch einfach
ausloggen. Leute, ich mach gleich wieder an.
Alternativ können wir uns auch einfach
ausloggen und
einen neuen Fake-Account machen.
Wir loggen uns einfach nochmal aus und machen
einen neuen Fake-Account.
Ist wahrscheinlich sinnvoller.
Okay.
Ihr seid wieder da.
Wir sind wieder da.
Set,
Setke.
Sign-up. Dann machen wir mal eine 10-Minute-Mail.
Ja, genau,
das Beste, das brauchen wir jetzt.
E-Mail, Dings hier,
nein, das mach ich nicht. Ich brauch irgendwas,
was ihr, was ihr
nicht seht. Clipboard
ausmachen. Und jetzt hoffen wir
mal, dass es das nicht
rüberdingst.
Ah, ja.
Okay.
Ist es
im Clipboard drinnen?
Nein, es ist nicht. Okay.
Clipboard wieder an.
Register.
Don't save.
So!
Excellent!
Da sind wir.
Richtig Setke sind die.
Ich werde euch jetzt mal erklären, um was es da
eigentlich geht. Wir machen jetzt die erste
Aufgabe nochmal.
Die dauert nämlich nur eine Minute oder so,
dass ihr seht, um was es geht.
Amazing! Dankeschön für den Sub.
Sorry, falls ich irgendjemanden übersehen hab,
aber ich glaube...
Das Splixer, auch wieder.
Anderen hab ich schon gesehen.
Inspektor Poops, den hab ich, glaub ich, nicht gesehen.
Huge Subscription.
Nice!
Chainlo, auch wieder am Start!
Excellent!
Gibt's den Friseur noch? Ja, den gibt's noch.
Der ist aber
kein Friseur mehr.
Zumindest das letzte, was ich gehört hab.
Das ändert sich beim Fabian ja öfters mal,
dass der mal was
Neues macht, aber ich glaube,
es ist noch aktuell.
Chainlo, ich hab keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
Ich will's wahrscheinlich aber auch gar nicht wissen.
Das ist Forsen. Okay, obviously.
Alles klar.
Erkennt man sofort, oder?
Ah, das sind die Linebreaks
halt nicht richtig, wenn man den Chat
im Fullscreen hat.
Stimmt, haben wir gar keine
Modges da gerade.
Dann muss ich modgen.
So. Also.
Ah, da ist er. Erster Modge am Start.
Wenn der Chainlo
nochmal Ascii Art spammt, kannst du gleich
schauen.
Also, ich zeige euch
jetzt nochmal, um was es bei der ganzen Sache geht.
Ich glaube, das ist von nem deutschen
Entwickler. Und
der hat sich gedacht,
es gibt so viele
Hackermän.
Ich wollt's grad sagen, Alter.
Das heißt jetzt nicht,
dass alle anderen Ascii Art spammen müssen.
Übrigens, das
hat jetzt sogar funktioniert
bei mir in der Stream-Forschung.
Da hab ich erkannt, dass das Forsen sein soll.
Also, ich erklär euch das jetzt mal.
Das ist ja schrecklich heute.
Gleich Timeout.
Richtig, so muss das
sein. Cake bye.
Wobei.
Eigentlich eher
der. Weil das würde ja bedeuten,
er lackt Critical Information.
Aber Chainlo lackt keine Critical Information.
Zumindest nicht, was das angeht.
Wo ist eigentlich Michael50Billiarden?
Den hab ich auch schon lange nicht mehr gesehen.
So ein paar Leute kennt man ja dann irgendwie
doch mit der Zeit.
Also im Prinzip sagen mir die meisten Namen
hier grad was im Chat.
Man sieht schon
wirklich sehr oft hier.
Da ist er wieder.
Sehr oft gleich, Leute.
Also, ich erklär euch jetzt mal, um was es geht.
Also, Set Servers ist eine,
ich glaube, von nem deutschen Entwickler ins Leben gerufene
Seite.
Und der hat sich gedacht, es gibt so viele
Hackerman-Challenge-Seiten,
wo du
irgendwelche
PHP-Sicherheitslücken
ausnutzen musst, irgendwelche Webserver-
Exploits-Geschichten. Es gibt auch was für
Kubernetes, wo du gucken kannst, was du als Sicherheitslücken findest.
Da ist ja immer so das gleiche Schema.
Man bekommt quasi
was vorgesetzt und
muss darauf dann quasi
was finden.
Wenn man es gefunden hat,
dann hat man halt
diese Challenge gepackt.
Dann kann man das nächste machen.
Im Hacker-Bereich
läuft das dann so unter CTF.
Bisschen was in die Richtung ist
das hier auch.
Nur,
dass das weniger
Programmier-Hacker-Fokus hat,
sondern mehr
Server ist kaputt
und man muss ihn wieder ganz machen.
Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass das Server absichtlich
kaputt gemacht wurde
und
es absichtlich so eingestellt
ist, dass es gar nicht
so einfach ist, ihn wieder ganz zu machen.
Also,
zumindest ab Medium.
Easy ist
wirklich easy. Ich denke mal,
easy bekommen die meisten Leute, die ein bisschen
Linux-Erfahrung haben, hin.
Ich zeige euch das jetzt auch mal exemplarisch.
Max,
erinnerst du dich? Das war doch bestimmt die Seite,
wo ich
die
Url verstecken muss, oder?
War das nicht so?
Ich glaube, da musste ich
die Url verstecken, weil sonst gab es irgendwie Probleme.
Ja, sonst konnte
der Chat wirklich den Server runterfahren.
Ja, ja,
ich erinnere mich noch dran.
Genau, also.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal ein Beispiel,
wie das Ganze aussieht.
Gehen wir mal auf die erste
Aufgabe unter Easy.
Auf Info kann man sich anzeigen
lassen, was denn das eigentliche Problem ist.
Also sprich, Level Easy,
Type, was man machen soll. Man soll das Ganze reparieren.
Access,
Public, was auch immer. Ach so, Public ist,
ob du dich eingeloggt haben musst oder nicht.
Das ist die Description.
Ein Entwickler hat ein
Testprogramm erstellt, das
die ganze Zeit nach var.log
.log schreibt.
Und das schreibt mit der Zeit eben
die Festplatte voll.
Man kann das Ganze überprüfen, indem man
sagt tail-f var.log
und dann sieht man, dass das die ganze Zeit reinschreibt.
Das Programm wird nicht mehr gebraucht.
Wir sollen rausfinden, wo das liegt
und das killen.
Also,
das ist tatsächlich nicht so schwierig.
Ich glaube, Chatge,
haben wir irgendwelche Leute, die nicht gesehen haben
im Chat,
die nicht zugeguckt haben,
wie ich die letzten
Aufgaben hier gemacht habe?
Dann dürft ihr nämlich...
Ich hab's noch nicht gesehen.
Also, dann seid mal
so fair, Chat.
Alle, die es schon gesehen haben, sagen mal nix.
Und
wir machen das jetzt mal chat-driven.
Okay?
Wir machen das jetzt mal chat-driven.
Der Chat sagt jetzt, was ich machen soll.
Dass ihr mal seht, um was es eigentlich geht.
So, wir gehen mal hier auf Run.
Wenn man auf Run drückt,
dann startet eine VM.
Das ist eine richtig echte Linux-VM
in AWS.
Url-Leak.
Max, ich hab doch hier extra was drüber.
Guck mal.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob's an der Stelle reicht,
aber dann sehen wir's gleich.
Moment, war die Url auch unten?
Nee, nee, war nicht.
Ha! Nice!
Kein Url-Leak, Leute.
Reicht sogar hier.
Kein Url-Leak.
Cack-Wait.
Okay, also, das ist
Chat-Gil, das ist unsere Aufgabe.
Ich zeig euch das mal.
tail-f
var log
bad.log
Und wir sehen, hier schreibt kontinuierlich was rein.
Wir sollen rausfinden, was reinschreibt.
Also, wir sollen rausfinden, was reinschreibt,
und das killen.
pipe-grep-auf-file
Nee, das ist mir zu vage.
Das geht aber auf jeden Fall in die richtige Richtung.
Es muss aber auch nicht ls-off sein.
Chat, Chat, was sollen wir machen?
Wie kriegen wir raus,
welches Programm da reinschreibt?
IP-Leak.
Oh, nein.
Kann man Eigenschaften der Datei anzeigen lassen?
Ja, kann man machen.
var log
bad.log
Oder wir können auch stat...
gucken.
Bringt ja aber auch nicht wirklich was.
H-Top und...
H-Top schauen und gucken, welches Programm
sass. Okay.
Ich war mal ein bisschen breiter.
Erkennt ihr irgendwas, was
sass ist hier drin?
Das ist auch eine Möglichkeit, das rauszubekommen,
aber nicht so, nicht so, sagen wir mal, nicht so elegant.
Der Chat ist im Weg.
Oh.
Ja, das macht nix.
Da steht nix Wichtiges.
So, Chat, wo sind
die Linux-Skills hier?
Also,
im Prinzip war die Antwort, die im Chat steht
gar nicht
so verkehrt, auch wenn mir das ein bisschen
wenig war, ehrlich gesagt.
Du machst ls-off
auf
var log bad log.
Äh, ja, wenn man das jetzt
noch richtig schreiben könnte.
Und dann siehst du, aha, guck mal.
Hier drauf greift gerade
das Ding dazu.
Mit dieser PID.
Command bad log.py
Oh, Chat ist im Weg.
Ah, jetzt aber.
Jetzt wird's aber anspruchsvoll hier.
Okay, wenn
der Chat im Weg ist, dann müssen
wir mal gucken.
Bin mir unschlüssig, wie wir das jetzt gescheit machen.
Weiß nicht, wie ich das gescheit anordnen kann.
Wir müssen den Chat...
Ich weiß, wie wir
das machen. Easy.
Oh, jetzt ist der Chat nicht mehr im Weg.
Lul.
Ich, Leute...
Der Chat wird aber auch so gar nicht groß
im Weg sein, denke ich.
Ich glaube,
ich glaube, so ist es okay.
Wir können auch
einfach den Browser rechts machen, wäre glaube ich noch sinnvoller.
Jetzt müssen wir nur
aufpassen, dass wir nicht zu viel leaken.
Ja, so, und jetzt können wir einfach sagen, Chat,
geht's weiter.
Was haben wir jetzt? Jetzt haben wir die PID rausgekriegt.
Ah, wir können auch PS-AUG oder irgendwas gucken,
aber ist egal. Jetzt haben wir die PID rausgekriegt.
Und was jetzt?
PID, richtig.
705.
Zack. Und jetzt
sieht man hier... Ups.
Tail.
Und jetzt sieht man, hier passiert nichts
mehr. Und...
Jetzt können wir sagen,
check my solution.
Und dann sagt er, jawoll, hast du gut
gemacht. Passt.
Nächste Aufgabe.
Ne, das war's schon. Ne, da steht nicht,
dass es nicht mehr starten soll. Da steht Plus drin.
Wir sollen fixen, dass es reinschreibt.
Ja, das war's im Prinzip.
So sieht es aus. Also das ist,
das ist
die Idee dahinter.
So, wir haben alles schon gemacht
von den Aufgaben, außer
die, die neu sind.
Also wir haben drei neue Aufgaben.
Wir haben Fun mit Mr.
Jason.
Irgendwie...
Keck...
French.
Dann haben wir
Paris.
Where is my web server?
Rabbit. Was? Ne, ne.
Ich wollte das jetzt nicht aufmachen.
Also Monaco
haben wir dann noch. Also die zwei.
Die zwei und die drei.
Keck Baguette.
Ne.
Lau... äh...
Rauch.
Dann wirst du es nicht sehen.
NSF zeigt nur offene
Pfeilhandels an.
Das heißt, wenn das Ding jetzt quasi
nur reinschreibt
und sich komplett wieder
beendet und dann wieder von
irgendwas gestartet wird und sich wieder
beendet und so, dann nicht.
Dann würdest du es nicht sehen.
Das würdest du aber auch rauskriegen.
Da müsstest du halt
LS auf ein bisschen öfters ausführen und gucken
was es ist. Also da kommt man dann
auch irgendwie dahinter.
Also ich glaube
Chat, ich glaube, sag mir das mal,
aber ich glaube man hat verstanden so prinzipiell
um was es geht, oder?
Man kriegt ne Aufgabe gestellt, muss es fixen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, das ist ja
easy.
Naja, das war jetzt auch
easy
Aufgabe 1. Das war wirklich
easy as fuck. Da waren auch echt
ein paar Dinger drin, da muss ich sagen, die waren nicht so
einfach. Ich glaube,
wir haben bisher erst eins nicht im
Zeitlimit geschafft.
Da weiß ich aber gar nicht mehr, was das war.
Das war tatsächlich gar keines
von den schweren. Ich glaube, das war wirklich
ne... Ne, war das das mit dem
Java-Ding, was wir nicht im Zeitlimit geschafft haben?
Ich glaube, das
Java
Jav-File, die
entpacken oder was das da gewesen ist.
Das hat... Ich glaube, das haben wir das erste Mal
nicht im Zeitlimit geschafft.
Weil ich absolut keinen Plan
von Java-Zeug hab. Nicht Javascript.
Ja. Also.
Wir fangen jetzt an.
Und zwar mit Unimog
Island. Fun mit Mr.
Jason.
Aufgabe ist folgende.
Also Level Medium, das sollen wir machen.
Using the file
stationinformation.json
Jason.
Okay, das liegt da irgendwo rum.
Und da sollen wir
wahrscheinlich das
Jason-Objekt finden, wo
stationid...
Ne.
Ach ne, wir sollen die stationid
rausbekommen, wo
hasKiosk gleich
false ist.
Und die Capacity größer als
3. Ich vermute mal, dass da halt ganz viele
Jason-Objects
drinstehen und wir das irgendwie rausgreppen
müssen oder so. Okay.
Save the stationid
of the sol... Was?
Save the stationid of the solution in the HomeAdmin
MySolution file.
Okay, so sieht ne ID aus.
MySolution.
Okay, was ist installiert? JQ.
Das ist schon mal sehr gut. Das ist meistens
alles, was man braucht für solche Dinge. Aber gucken
wir uns das mal an. Da gibt's noch
Gron.
Shit.
Ja, das ist jetzt aber doof.
Ich dachte eigentlich schon,
dass man Git-Shit ausspricht.
Spricht man das jetzt aus?
Python und Golang.
Na.
Okay. Ich würde sagen,
wir machen das nochmal ein bisschen
schwieriger.
Wir dürfen sowohl Python als auch Go
nicht verwenden. Das muss ne reine
Shell-Solution sein.
Interaktiv in der Shell. Ohne
Shell-Scripting, ohne Python-Scripts, ohne
Go, ohne irgendwas.
So, dann würde ich sagen, auf geht's.
Let's go.
Fahren mit Mr. Jason.
Run.
Haben wir sonst noch irgendwas hier?
Ach ja, und falls ihr es nicht gesehen
habt,
man kann sich manchmal auch Hinweise
einblenden lassen, wenn man nicht mal weiter weiß.
Steht auch hier. Da kann man dann sagen
Next Clue. Und wenn man gar keine Ahnung
hat, kann man sich auch einen Lösungsvorschlag
anzeigen lassen. Es gibt bei
vielen der
Aufgaben mehrere Lösungen.
Also Lösungswege.
So, jetzt müssen wir kurz warten, bis die
VM da ist. Und dann schauen wir
uns das Ganze mal an. Ihr könnt mitraten.
Oder was heißt raten? Ihr könnt
mitbasteln. Also ihr könnt so viel spammen im Chat
dazu, was ihr wollt.
Aber, also ihr dürft
heute backseaten, wie ihr Bock habt.
Aber, erwartet nicht,
dass ich alles, was im Chat geschrieben wird, 1 zu 1
so rüber copy-paste und ausprobiere.
Letztendlich muss ich ja schon selbst
dahinter kommen. Aber ihr könnt mit, ihr könnt backseaten,
wie ihr lustig seid heute.
So, ich warte noch auf die VM.
Mal was trinken.
Ich bin immer noch unschlüssig,
ob ich die Stream-Kategorie auf Software
und Game Development lassen soll oder auf Just Chatting.
Es trifft's nicht
so wirklich. Beides nicht.
Ur-Leak-Ink
oder geht das? Das sollte gehen. Ich hab da oben
extra ein Terminal drüber, das ist nicht...
Ey, guckt, da wird
nix geleakt. No
leak.
So, also, was haben
wir denn hier? Wir
haben... Wie heißt die
Datei? Station
Information. So, gucken wir erst mal,
ob die hier rumliegt. Station
Information.json
Dann lasst uns doch erst mal
erzählen, was da...
Was?
Ist das alles in einer Zeile?
Keck!
Okay, das ist alles
in einer Zeile hier. Das ist... Woah!
Alter, das ist ja badig. Na gut.
Dann würde ich mal sagen...
Ja, das ist schon einiges.
Dann pipen wir das doch als erstes mal
nach jq und gucken uns mal an,
was für Objekte da drin sind.
Und dann mal nach less.
Also, wir sollen
rausfinden, bei welchem
JSON-Objekt, also wahrscheinlich sehen
die Dinger alle mehr oder weniger so aus,
bei welchem JSON-Objekt
HasKioskFalse ist.
Und
Capacity
größer als 30.
Sag mal. Has
Kiosk
True, true, true.
Okay.
Wir scheißen mal komplett
auf Grab oder irgendwas.
Okay, HasKiosk
False.
Capacity 32.
Moment. Ist das schon das Ergebnis?
Das kann nicht sein, oder?
Da muss...
Moment, Moment. Was?
Ist das ernsthaft?
Moment, was haben wir denn sonst noch so?
Wir haben False.
Da ist die Capacity 20.
Und das war's.
Das ist das Ergebnis. Fertig. Easy.
Hahaha.
Okay, bevor ich jetzt lage,
rumschwärts.
Und wo soll das jetzt hin?
Nach
my
x-the-solution.
My solution.
Okay.
Less.
My solution. Okay.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Das würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt als Medium
kennzeichnen.
Vielleicht haben wir auch einfach das Outplayed.
Vielleicht
haben wir es einfach Outplayed,
indem wir
es gar nicht angefangen haben, da mit
JQ oder irgendwas dran zu gehen,
sondern einfach Letztes gesucht, Alter.
Hahaha.
Okay.
Das war eigentlich einfacher, als ich es mir vorgestellt habe.
Das war easy.
Das war wirklich easy.
Okay, more scenarios.
Gut, Chat.
Ihr dürft euch aussuchen, was wir als nächstes machen.
Wir haben zur Auswahl
Also, das haben wir.
Das haben wir hier.
Sieht man jetzt eigentlich
auch sein Ranking
oder so?
Ach, ich habe auf Lockout gedrückt.
Ich kack nu, Alter.
Ich kack nu, Mann.
Dann muss ich wieder
Login machen.
Lockout.
Login.
Und jetzt dürft ihr nicht gucken,
Chat. Augen zu machen, okay?
Ihr dürft nicht das Passwort sehen.
Augen zu.
Habt ihr zu?
Kann ich Passwort einfügen?
Guckt keiner?
Gut.
Wir haben es geschafft. Wir sind wieder da.
Und ich habe es auch nicht geleakt.
Sehr schön.
Gut.
Wo sehe ich jetzt hier mein Dashboard?
Ja, die zwei Sachen haben wir jetzt
gemacht. Time 2 Minuten 54 von
15.
Gut. Linux
World Cup
Scenarios.
Okay, ihr dürft
euch aussuchen. Also, was wollen wir machen?
Wir haben zur Auswahl
Wir gucken uns mal die Info an.
Wir gucken uns mal die Infos an dazu.
Wir gucken uns mal die Infos an. Also,
wir haben Baguette.
Aufgabe.
Ne, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf. Wir haben eben
ein JSON-File gemacht. Jetzt muss ich kein CSV-File
machen. Also, hier gibt es ein
CSV-File.
Table.
Tableau.
Tableau. Wie man das ausspricht.
JSON. Und da sollen wir
Elektoral
District Name
Nomde. Das kann ich nicht
aussprechen.
Rausfinden, dass die largest number of
rejected was auch immer
hat und
die Population kleiner als
100.000 ist. Oh, hier, okay.
Hier müssen wir also CSV-Dateien
parsen. Oh, ne, da habe ich jetzt echt keinen Bock
drauf.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Das machen wir jetzt nicht. Dann haben wir
jetzt, where is my web server?
Hackerman.
Info.
Okay.
Ein Entwickler hat
...
Okay.
Ein Entwickler hat ein wichtiges Passwort
auf seinem Web-Server.
Localhost 5000. Da speichere ich
auch immer alles auf Localhost.
Localhost Port 5000 gespeichert.
Er kann jedoch keine Möglichkeit finden,
es wieder herzustellen.
Es ist einfach zu lösen, wenn man einen Trick
kennt.
Kenn ich einen Trick? Keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir gleich sehen.
Finden Sie das Passwort und speichern Sie es da.
Alles. What the fuck?
So, das ist eins.
Das können wir machen. Und dann haben wir
noch zur Auswahl
das da.
Oh, RapidMQ.
MonkaS.
MonkaW.
RapidMQ.
Dann haben wir noch das zur Auswahl.
In der Datei docker-compose.yaml
ist ein Rapid...
Also ich hab schon gesehen, die meisten von euch
werden Web-Server machen.
Das machen wir wahrscheinlich auch gleich.
Also in der Datei docker-compose.yaml
ist ein RapidMQ-Cluster definiert.
Starten Sie dieses System
und fügen Sie dann das Skript
producer.py aus.
Sodass es Nachrichten
an RapidMQ senden kann. Insbesondere müssen
Sie Nachrichten hello.lwc senden.
RapidMQ
bla bla bla
Nachrichten werden mit einem Producer in die Warteschlange
gestellt und auf der anderen Seite von einem
Consumer abgeholt. Der Name der Warteschlange muss
für beide derselbe sein.
Um die Nachricht
hello.lwc zu senden
python3 producer hello.lwc
sollte die an RapidMQ
gesendete Nachricht zurückgeben.
Incompatible protocol error.
Das bedeutet, dass das nicht funktioniert.
Das Konsumieren zu testen.
Okay, von RapidMQ habe ich echt
keinen Plan. So, und dann hätten wir als
letzte Aufgabe noch
Monaco.
Webserver auf Port 5000
und
irgendwo eine Form auf der Webseite
und wenn man ein Post-Request schickt
mit dem korrekten Passwort, dann
bekommt man ein Secret zurück und das Secret
soll man da reinpasten. Okay, done.
Dann würde ich sagen, wir machen
erstmal den Webserver hier
und danach vielleicht den Webserver.
Ist ja beides erstmal
vielleicht ein bisschen ähnlich gelagert.
Müssen wir mal schauen. Also, machen wir das
hier mal. Where is my Webserver? Run.
Dauert jetzt 50 Sekunden.
Lass uns die Aufgabe
nochmal durchlesen, dass wir Bescheid wissen.
Also, Localhost
Port 5000. Läuft ein Webserver.
Er weiß nicht,
wie er wieder an das Passwort kommt.
Und
es ist easy zu lösen,
wenn man einen Trick kennt.
Uh.
Mal gucken. Mal gucken.
Ich hab absolut wirklich noch gar keine
Vorstellung, was das sein könnte.
Ich hab gar keine Ahnung,
was das sein könnte.
Also, ist das
ein Apache? Dann muss ich schon wieder kotzen gleich.
Curl.
Weiß nicht.
Find the Password and save it
in HomeAdminMySolution.
For example, echo some Password.
Okay, also.
Anscheinend müssen wir erstmal wirklich die Seite
curlen. Ich denke auch mal,
dass wir keinen Root-Zugang haben.
Wir können einfach das Passwort
zurücksetzen. Ne, können wir wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil wir, denke ich, kein...
Moment. Wir sind... Ja, nur, weil
Admin-User weiß es nicht, dass wir Root-Rechte
haben. Gucken wir mal.
Ich bin gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Müssen wir uns ein bisschen lang
hangeln. Okay. Open Terminal.
Let's go.
Chat, ich hoffe, ihr seht hier was.
Also, netstat
minus tulm. Guck mal, da ist
ein Webserver.py. Schau mal.
Was? Und das gehört
Root-Webserver.py.
Ah, permission, permission denied.
Aber...
Wir haben keine Rechte auf
Webserver.py. Die Frage ist
vielleicht, ist das auch nur Jibade?
Und wir brauchen
Webserver.py an der Stelle gar
nicht. Es läuft auf jeden Fall
auf 8080
ein... Ein was?
Ah ne, Moment.
Auf Port 5000 sind wir ja.
Port 5000. Okay.
Pseudo-Rechte haben wir bestimmt keine.
Das hab ich mir fast
schon gedacht. Also.
Call local
host
Port 5000.
Unauthorized.
Ja, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken. Okay.
Was... Was könnten wir da machen?
Lasst uns nochmal kurz hier das Verzeichnis
angucken. Was ist es denn
überhaupt für ein Webserver? Finden wir hier
irgendwas vielleicht? Hier.
Leute, ich muss das mal ein bisschen kleiner machen.
Erkennt man noch
genug, ja?
Irgendwie Webserver oder so? Können wir uns das aus...
Ah ja, hier. Das läuft.
User bin python home
admin webserver.py
Also, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
ist es das.
So, was haben wir denn sonst noch hier rumliegen?
Es gibt
einen Punkt Config, einen Punkt Ansible.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nichts, was damit
zu tun hat. Aber wir können mal reingucken.
Ne, das ist für das Setup.
Das ist für das Setup.
Okay.
Ich vermute mal, wir müssen irgendwie
rausfinden,
wie wir in
webserver.py
reingucken können.
Hm. Okay, da habe ich
jetzt erstmal keine Ahnung, was wir
machen können. So,
lasst uns mal irgendwie blubbern.
Not found, okay.
Das...
Schau mal, nix.
In der Bash hast du nichts.
Können wir irgendwie
sowas machen?
Irgendwie sowas?
Äh.
Ups. Wait a minute. Was hat
meine... Warte mal.
Was hat meine Shell da draus gemacht gerade?
Puh. Jetzt da habe ich echt
keine Ahnung gerade, was wir machen können.
Hm.
Ich meine...
Ne, das glaube ich nicht, dass das
funktioniert, Chat.
Das hat auch... Das ist ein Python
Webserver. Das interessiert
HTDingsbums und so nicht.
Was passiert denn damit jetzt?
Das ist irgendein Python
Spezialkram, den man dazu vielleicht
nutzen muss. Schreibt das Ding
irgendwie einen Log oder so?
Was ist denn hier nochmal in Config alles drin?
Ne, da ist nichts drin.
Hat das irgendeinen Log oder so?
Ne.
Aber da können wir auch nicht reingucken.
Aber das bringt uns auch nichts.
Boah, jetzt bin ich echt ein bisschen...
Also ich würde ja
sagen, wir müssen irgendwie gucken, wie wir da
reingucken können vielleicht.
Schade, dass das nicht
x hat für uns.
Dann könnten wir da reingucken.
Wir haben da nichts...
Wir haben da nichts wirklich drauf.
Wir können mal...
Sieht man irgendwas
hier drin? In Config gibt es Ansible, gibt es
History, gibt es...
Ich habe eine Idee.
Wir gucken uns mal den curl output an.
Server, okay.
Wir wissen schon mal, was das ist.
Das ist ein Werkzeugserver.
Was auch immer.
Ähm...
Mal gucken, ob es da irgendeinen Bug oder so gibt.
Ist das Flask?
Kann man da irgendwo
irgendwas tricksen?
Das kann es ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Okay, not found.
Okay, wir können
mal...
Okay, wir machen mal mit curl
basic auth
minus u.
Minus u.
Ja, machen wir einfach mal.
Das geht
wirklich so?
Unauthorized.
Da fällt mir echt wenig ein.
Jetzt.
Außer, dass es ein Python ist.
Also...
Vielleicht liegt das Pfeil hier...
Das muss doch einen Sinn haben, dass das Pfeil hier liegt, oder?
Der das Ding startet.
Wahrscheinlich,
nicht?
Okay, wir müssen einen Trick kennen.
Das fand ich sehr gut.
Das mit dem
basic auth
ein Semikolon einbauen, finde ich
gut.
Ja, das interessiert das aber nicht.
Also...
Ich bin jetzt echt ein bisschen planlos,
was man da machen soll. Also, ich würde ja...
Ich würde ja...
Das können wir tatsächlich machen.
Das ist tatsächlich keine schlechte Idee.
Ja, das da.
Webserver.
Ja.
Aber...
Einen killen kann ich es garantiert auch nicht.
Ich bin nicht Ruth.
Bringt auch nichts.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Können wir das Pfeil
moven?
Eigentlich nicht.
Aha.
Moment.
Wir können das Pfeil
moven.
Das finde ich schon mal ganz spannend.
Also, das geht ja offensichtlich
nicht.
Aber...
Können das Pfeil moven?
Warte mal.
Haben wir Zugriff auf...
Wo liegt denn das Ganze?
Haben wir Zugriff
auf dev?
NVME?
N1?
P1?
Das wäre jetzt auch zu einfach.
Okay, wir können das Pfeil moven.
Ja, wenn das geht, wäre natürlich
extremely nice. Nein, das geht nicht.
Ich meine, hätten wir
Execute-Rechte. Hätten wir Execute-Rechte,
dann könnten wir was machen.
Es reichen
Execute-Rechte, glaube ich, um das
zu lesen. Ich meine,
ich kann es sicherlich nicht...
Gibt es sowas wie...
Read, move...
Pfeil, Linux.
Gibt es da irgendeinen super krassen Trick, den ich nicht kenne?
Dass man...
Aber das ist doch zumindest schon mal ein Ansatz.
Wir können die Datei moven.
Okay, ich weiß, was wir machen.
Und jetzt...
This can be used to... Oh, guck mal.
Interessant.
This can be used to move and then read
file from a restricted file system.
Warte mal.
Touch?
Ich meine, wir können...
Wenn ich das jetzt curle...
Okay, der hat das einmalig
eingelesen. Das bringt mir überhaupt nichts, wenn ich
die Datei ändere.
Aber ich muss ja nur reingucken können
in die Datei.
Was ist das? Das kenne ich nicht.
Sudo install...
Was bin ich...
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Was soll das sein?
This can be used to...
Das bringt mir nichts, weil...
Das habe ich hier nicht drauf. Ich kann ja nichts nachinstallieren.
Okay.
Linux, read, move,
moveable file. Da gibt es... Ich kenne den Trick
nicht.
Kugel! Kugel!
Da kommen wir nicht weiter.
Also jetzt...
Das ist eine gute Idee, Professor. So etwas in der Richtung.
Ich habe jetzt wirklich gerade
absolut keine Ahnung.
Ja, okay.
Bevor wir das nochmal starten, dann müssen wir
uns echt überlegen. Okay, was
könnte das sein?
Es ändert sich nichts,
wenn ich es move.
Okay, wir können uns
ja mal...
Wir können uns ja mal den ersten Hint angucken.
Okay.
Check clue. Next clue.
The user agent
of the client we are using against
the web server may play... Aha!
Ah!
Okay.
Vielleicht sollten
wir mal so tun, als sind wir Mozilla Firefox
oder sowas.
Ich glaube, wir müssen es neu starten,
damit der Server abgekackt ist.
Warten wir mal.
Ich habe gerade
was gefunden. Das probieren wir jetzt mal
aus. Ich habe gerade was gefunden.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
The dark side of the MV
command. Vielleicht ist das
der Trick, den er meint. Ich hätte keine Ahnung gehabt,
dass das geht.
Und da kann man dann solche Sachen
machen, wie...
Also ganz gecheckt habe ich...
Moment, ich kann hier ja nichts cp'n.
Könnte das sein,
dass wenn ich die Datei move,
über eine Datei, die es schon
gibt...
Keine Ahnung.
Müssen wir mal schauen. Das ist tatsächlich
das Erste, was richtig schwierig ist.
Also,
das haben wir schon mal.
MV web server...
touch keckel.lul
Und jetzt
moven wir mal webserver.py
nach keckel.lul
Äh...
Ne, hat nicht funktioniert.
Das hätte mich auch gewundert.
Der user agent.
Okay, dann probieren wir das mal aus.
curl set user agent
Das ist minus H
oder so was.
Oder minus A
Nee, H ist header.
Das geht auf jeden Fall.
Und...
Okay, standardmäßig
setzt der
Minus VVV
So, standardmäßig
sagt er, dass er user agent curl ist.
Dann
sagen wir ihm doch jetzt mal, dass er
nicht user agent curl ist.
Ups, sondern wir sagen,
dass er user agent
So, das funktioniert nicht.
Dass er user agent
Sag mal...
Ich glaub, ich weiß, dass das die...
Äh, das war's?
Hä?
Okay, das ist ne blöde Aufgabe.
Das hat ja nichts mit wirklich großartig
gucken und überlegen
Das ist
so was, wo man früher oder später
vielleicht drauf kommt,
das mal auszuprobieren.
Ja, es gibt durchaus Server, die curl
blocken, aber
naja, ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Also, das finde ich
nicht so geil, die Aufgabe.
Mal gucken, ob wir es jetzt geschafft haben.
Wobei, ich will eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Ich will es eigentlich gar nicht ausprobieren.
Okay, was sollen wir machen?
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken, ob das...
Hab ich nicht.
User bin, hab ich nicht.
Wär ja auch
weird champ, oder?
Funktioniert das jetzt?
MV ist immer noch MV.
Cannot move.
Jaja, okay.
Gut, dann ist das tatsächlich
die Lösung, aber die finde ich
irgendwie doof.
Also sprich, hier
curl, hier ist das Passwort.
Und das sollen wir jetzt reinschreiben
nach...
My
Solution
Check.
Ja, keine Ahnung, also das fand ich jetzt
irgendwie ein bisschen weird.
Klar, das hätte man mal eh...
Das ist so ein Ding, das probiert man halt irgendwann mal aus
und gut ist.
Ich hätte immer noch ganz gerne Zugriff auf
Webserver.py bekommen.
Wir müssen mal schauen.
Jetzt hab ich set servers.
Ob das Source Code da irgendwo
liegt.
Würde es einfach mal interessieren.
Ich mein, das ist halt schon irgendwie Meta-Gaming.
Das ist halt echt ein bisschen...
Okay, da ist anscheinend
gibt es da nichts zu.
Wär tatsächlich ganz interessant gewesen.
Das wär cool. Ich hätte auch gerne mal reingeguckt
in das Webserver.py.
Letztendlich war das wahrscheinlich einfach
nur ein If-User-Agent, gleich, gleich
curl, dann
unauthorized, wenn nicht curl.
Das ist komisch gewesen, also weiß nicht.
Das...
More Scenarios, WeirdChamp.
So, das haben wir jetzt gemacht.
Was haben wir hier noch übrig?
CSV-Dateien. Boah, hab ich da
Bock drauf.
Was ist Miller?
Querying, Shaping and Reformatting
Data-Files in various formats.
Okay.
Postgres ist drauf.
MySQL ist drauf.
Moment, was sollen wir
noch mal machen?
Wir haben eine CSV-Datei.
Und da drinnen sollen wir das da finden,
das die largest number
of rejected...
was auch immer hat.
Und eine population...
Oh, CSV ist so ein abartiges
Format, man.
Wollen wir das ausprobieren? Ja, komm.
Let's go.
Moment, MD5?
Achso, hier kriegen wir die...
Können wir testen, ob es funktioniert.
Vielleicht sollen wir auch
Miller direkt in eine SQLite-Datenbank...
Vielleicht sollen wir das CSV auch in eine
SQLite-Datenbank packen,
um dann... Pass mal auf!
FiverTime. Wir packen das
in eine SQLite-Datenbank
und machen dann eine SQL-Query dagegen.
Leute, Vorbereitung
ist alles. Geht das damit?
Kann man damit irgendwie
was formatieren?
CSV?
SQLite.
Geht das irgendwie?
Import CSV zu SQLite?
Moment, das funktioniert?
Man kann in SQLite
CSV importieren?
Wusstet ihr das? Das geht?
Da bin ich jetzt aber echt
gespannt.
Da bin ich wirklich jetzt gespannt, ob das...
Okay, wo sind wir?
Ähm, hier.
Run.
Ich persönlich
würde ja fast wieder mit
GREP und AWK
und SEED und so da rumwurschten,
aber gucken wir erst mal rein.
Lass uns doch mal kurz gucken, was wir machen müssen.
Wir sollen das da finden,
dass die meisten
rejected
Barlots
was auch immer hat
und eine Population
kleiner
100.000. Okay.
Pass mal auf,
ich hab ne Idee.
Wir machen jetzt mal
Shell Magic.
Gleich.
Ich probier mal was aus.
Ich glaube,
das müssen wir zweimal ausprobieren.
Einmal mit reiner Shell Magic
und dann mit SQLite.
Das mit SQLite finde ich einfach
sehr spannend, weil mit SQLite
könnte man dann einfach sagen,
Select from...
Muss mal gucken, wie das aufgebaut ist.
Okay, zack.
Okay, auf geht's.
Also, was haben wir hier liegen?
Table?
Okay, es ist tatsächlich
richtig echt Komma-separated.
Lass uns mal kurz schauen.
Also, das erste ist der...
Was sollen wir rauskriegen?
District. Das zweite.
Das zweite. Okay.
Wir brauchen die zweite Spalte.
Electoral
District Name.
Nomen irgendwas.
Transdingskription.
Kronskription.
Können wir nicht so was
machen? Ich hab ne Idee, Leute.
Können wir nicht ganz simpel so was machen?
Cut field.
Cut dings.
Field.
Zwei. So. Das sind die ganzen...
Das sind jetzt die ganzen...
Tja, wie auch immer.
Wie heißen sie?
Nomde...
Dingspunks.
Kription. So, da ist jetzt Minus
hinten dran. Schmeißen alles raus.
Und da haben wir jetzt
quasi die Dinger
vorne stehen.
Und jetzt sollen wir
raussuchen, dass was... Moment.
Das...
Eine Population.
Ah, ich bin ein Kacknup.
Was ist davon die... Moment, Moment.
Was ist die Population?
Die Population ist...
Das...
Wir machen das mal mit Shellmittel.
Danach machen wir es nochmal mit SQLite.
Boah, das ist ja mal
voll abartig.
Das erste.
Das zweite.
Das dritte. Die Population ist
das...
Nee. Das vierte.
Das vierte ist die
Population. Okay.
Und das ganze nochmal.
Das vierte ist die Population.
Wobei...
Moment, Moment.
Das bringt uns jetzt
nicht viel. Aber doch, doch, doch.
Alter. Diese
Webkonsole ist ja mal... Alter!
Die Webkonsole ist ja mal
so krass pp-iger, man.
Okay.
Dann machen wir das.
Ist im Prinzip wurscht.
Dann machen wir jetzt mal drei.
Und jetzt... Warte mal. Vier.
So, das ist die Population.
Das ist die Population.
So. Wir suchen ein, dass
eine Population
kleiner
100.000 hat.
Also.
Sort.
Ähm.
Die haben alle eine Population
kleiner als 100.000.
Hä?
Wollen die mich gebaten?
Ist es gebaten?
Province. Eins.
Zwei.
Drei. Vier.
Aber wenn ich jetzt einfach mal... Ich nehme drei.
Das war doch schon richtig, ne?
Okay.
Die haben alle unter
100.000.
Ach.
Sort minus N.
Okay. Sort minus N.
Alter.
Sort minus N ist es. Ja. Okay.
Okay.
Numeric. Wir wollen nicht Buchstaben.
Numeric wollen wir sorten.
So. Und jetzt unter 100.000.
Und dann...
Was muss noch sein?
Das Französische
macht mich ganz verrückt.
Largest number
of rejected.
Okay. Von den kleinen 100.000
rejected.
Alter. Das macht mich echt
durcheinander. Hier. Wo ist das?
Rejected.
Ähm. Wo steht denn das überhaupt?
Hier.
Rejected.
Sekunde. Wir müssen das mal kurz hier
aufmachen.
Und...
Ich brauch mal
Set. No. Wrap?
Wrap?
Okay. Schon besser.
Also. So.
Eins.
Zwei. Drei.
Vier.
Ne. Fünf.
Populä... Vier.
Fünf. Sechs.
Sieben. Acht.
Wie heißt der Shit nochmal?
Acht. Oder?
Eins. Eins.
Zwei.
Drei. Vier.
Fünf. Sechs.
Sieben.
Acht.
Acht wollen wir haben.
Das Achte. Das Achte.
Oder?
Das ist auf die Art und Weise
schon ein bisschen eklig.
So. Das sort-n.
Das leiten wir jetzt um in
blub.txt.
Äh. Wat?
So. Jetzt gehen wir runter. Unter 100.000.
So.
Schmeißen es weg.
Haben wir hier ein Pfeil drinnen.
Ich glaub wir runnen low on time.
Leute.
MonkaTime.
Und jetzt wollen wir... Boah. Das ist eklig.
Jetzt wollen wir hier blub.
Cut.
Minus D.
Wieder am Komma. Field.
Äh.
Boah.
Wartet mal.
Wir haben das Erste weggelassen.
Jetzt haben wir das Vierte.
Das heißt jetzt wollen wir
das...
Jetzt wollen wir das Achte haben.
Boah. Fuck.
Hoffentlich stimmt das. Lul. Alter.
So. Und da jetzt das...
Hoffentlich ist es das jetzt.
Das Französisch macht mich durcheinander. Alter.
Okay.
Das mit dem Latsch ist... Also hier.
Die da.
Das da ist es.
Glaub ich.
Ich glaub das ist es.
Das Letzte hier. Sechs irgendwas.
Ja.
Es gibt es auch nur einmal. Also British...
British Columbia
Britain Dingsbums.
British Columbia.
Okay.
Echo.
Ich hoffe das stimmt jetzt.
Nach.
My solution.
Fuck.
Shit.
Ah shit ey. Jetzt hab ich irgendwas.
Moment.
Ist das überhaupt richtig?
Was soll man da überhaupt reinschreiben?
Was soll denn überhaupt rauskommen
hier?
Save the solution is...
Name has...
Echo...
ist...
Was ist denn das hier überhaupt?
Ist das das am Anfang von der Datei?
Ne. Moment.
Das ist das Zweite.
Ich hab das Falsche.
Ich will hier South Dingsbums
Süd
Konga
Quest. Was auch immer das ist.
Das will ich haben.
Jetzt hätten wir mal die Aufgabe...
richtig...
richtig durchgelesen.
Das will ich haben.
My solution.
Das kann doch nicht wirklich so heißen oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht was der wissen will
von mir alter.
Was? Ich hab es von unten kopiert?
Ne.
Ich würde es ja gerne im WIM aufmachen.
Moment. Hä?
What the fuck?
Das will ich haben. Aber hier kann ich nicht raus...
Alter wie mich das abfängt.
Wie heißt das Ding hier?
Kovicchan.
Was?
Ach scheiße.
Alter.
Okay. Ich glaube ich muss die Aufgabe
nochmal lesen. Ob ich es auch wirklich gecheckt
habe was da rein soll.
Weil das Französisch macht mich so
durcheinander alter.
Wir müssen das glaube ich gleich nochmal neu starten.
Ich will das einmal mit
Schellmittel und einmal mit
in SQL Dump machen.
Was? The initial
CSV file may be corrupted?
What?
Ja ist das denn überhaupt das was der wissen will?
Woher weiß ich denn? Welches Fell will er denn
wissen von mir?
Fine. District.
So was davon ist der District? Das zweite.
Das zweite.
Ne dann war das doch...
Dann war das doch eigentlich...
Kovicchan Malat
Langford.
Dann war das das was ich raus
gefunden habe. Okay. Dann ist mein
Sort verkehrt.
Ist es denn
vielleicht... Habe ich mich denn vielleicht
verzählt?
Ist es denn vielleicht...
Das da?
Es kann auch sein dass ich mich einfach verzählt habe.
Ja Kat 8.
Aber ich habe doch vorher schon eins
weggelöscht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich richtig.
Warum kann ich denn hier nicht kopieren?
Alter das fuckt mich ab.
Set.
No Mouse? Ne ach man wie macht man
Maus aus?
Ach keine Ahnung.
Ist das vielleicht die Maus kaputt?
Ach Set Maus.
Ja Maus.
Jetzt kann ich auch copy paste.
Nice. Okay.
Sandings
Bums
My Solution.
Check.
Ey keine Ahnung.
F12
Tools.
Also
das scheint mir richtig zu
sein was ich hier gemacht habe.
Da fehlt jetzt...
Moment.
Ich habe fehlt
1 bis 4 genommen.
1 bis...
Moment ne 4.
Das heißt im Endeffekt es ist totaler Blödsinn
was ich da mache.
Es ist 4 bis oder?
Wenn ich eigentlich
8 haben will.
Ja das ist halt wenn man für Pega im Kopf
ist.
Ja.
Komm hier Grab.
Okay und jetzt... Moment das hatten wir doch gerade schon.
Das hatten wir gerade schon.
Das hatten wir auch
gerade schon.
Probieren wir mal das.
Das hatten wir auch schon.
Okay.
Das hatten wir doch auch schon da drinnen stehen.
Ich glaube wir sollten das doch
mit irgendeiner Datenbank Geschichte machen.
Moment das hatten wir doch gerade da drinnen stehen.
In der Solution die du
gefunden hast fehlt zwischen der ersten
und der zweiten Spalte das Komma.
Oh nein. Ernsthaft?
Das RCSV Datei ist kaputt?
Ja dann kann das überhaupt nicht funktionieren was ich hier mache.
Das steht ja sogar da.
The initials...
Oh shit.
Alter.
Fuck.
Jetzt wird es aber abartig.
Ich glaube die Zeit
ist auch bald um. Wie viel Zeit haben wir denn?
20 Minuten das müsste eigentlich schon längst um sein.
Okay.
Ähm.
Was haben wir denn hier für Tools drinnen die uns da irgendwie
helfen können?
Go.
Miller.
Das müssen wir doch irgendwie mit Shell-Tools alleine hinkriegen.
Also.
Wir können.
Oh mein Krepp. Krepp minus C.
Komma.
In.
Kann Krepp das?
Kann Krepp das irgendwie zeilenweise?
Ich meine wir können.
Das es nicht insgesamt
zählt.
Ich meine wir können eine Schleife drüber machen.
Das ist aber auch nicht.
Krepp count line-wise.
Geht das?
Ja. Das will ich genau wissen.
Seht.
Exzellent.
Okay.
Stagger overflow five at time.
Seht. Und jetzt suchen wir.
Ne Moment das ist Anfang.
Das ergibt doch gar keinen Sinn.
Ne Moment.
Wir suchen nicht. Wir suchen das was.
Nicht.
Moment. Das funktioniert? Wirklich?
Tatsächlich.
Ach guck mal.
Die erste.
Die erste Zeile hat nur.
Die erste Zeile hat nur zwölf.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Ansonsten haben alle 13.
Aber das hat doch.
Ja doch.
Ne ne. Okay. Okay. Wir haben mehr.
Ach du Scheiße.
Das CSV ist ja komplett falsch formatiert.
Wir haben.
Ach du Kacke.
Okay. Jetzt ist die Zeit um.
Alter.
Okay. Das ist ja massiv.
Bevor wir das neu starten.
Lasst mal kurz in uns gehen.
Wir können.
Moment.
The initial CSV file may be corrupt in a way
that can be fixed without changing
its data.
Was will er uns damit sagen?
Dass ich die Datei nicht editieren soll?
Oder dass ich.
Hä?
Also wir können.
Da fehlen.
Da fehlen Kommas.
Das heißt ich muss jetzt erstmal
in das CSV reingehen und die Kommas fixen?
Wisst ihr was?
Wetten das in einem
der Zeilen die falsch sind auch die Lösung
drin ist?
Kann das sein? Das könnte durchaus sein.
Dass in der Zeile.
In einem der Zeilen das kaputt ist.
Ja.
Das guck mal. Es sind drei
Zeilen insgesamt.
Wir brauchen jetzt nur.
Wir brauchen jetzt nur die Zeile.
Wir brauchen nur die Zeile.
Ich würde es
jetzt anders machen.
Ich würde jetzt.
Ich meine wir können eine Schleife über die Datei
machen.
Ich probiere das einfach mal.
Bevor wir da lange überlegen.
Ich mache eine Schleife.
Ich mache eine Schleife über die Datei.
Kannst du das nicht mit cat-n
pipen lassen?
Boah.
Wirklich.
Das ist eigentlich gar keine schlechte Idee.
Dann haben wir die line number vorne.
Aber das bringt uns nichts.
Weil.
Am Ende zählen wir ja nur.
Da muss ich mal gucken.
Das machen wir.
Wir machen das.
Ich habe eine Idee.
Was?
Und dann?
Achso.
Ja.
Ich habe mir was ähnliches überlegt.
Und danach.
Probieren wir es auf jeden Fall nochmal mit der Datenbank Lösung.
Also das ist bis jetzt.
Die zwei waren bis jetzt
die schwierigsten. Wobei das letzte echt einfach nur
pipega war mit dem user agent.
So.
Also.
Wir machen jetzt einfach was hier.
For i in.
Jetzt werden sich alle freuen.
Useless use
of cat.
Oder?
Hä?
Was ist mit meiner shell?
Ich verpflichte das nicht.
Weil das wird nicht funktionieren.
Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Wegen line separator.
Genau.
Nur backslash n.
Oh shit.
While do while.
Oh Gott.
Aber chat.
Die Idee finde ich prinzipiell schon mal gut von euch.
Ja.
Do while.
Read.
Bash.
Read while.
Wie ging das?
While.
Read.
Do echo.
Okay.
Schon mal nicht schlecht.
Gucken wir mal.
Ob das auch funktioniert.
Ja.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir das teilenweise.
Und jetzt können wir sagen.
Crap minus c.
Eins.
Count.
Kann das?
Fuck.
Guck mal da lernt man echt was.
Macht crap nur einmal pro line.
Wenn er was gefunden hat.
Und dann.
Interessant.
Bash.
Count.
Count of character in a string using bash.
Moment geht das echt?
Mit crap nicht?
Tatsächlich.
Crap interessiert es ja nur ob es auf der Zeile ist.
Wo hatte ich den?
Ich habe doch hier irgendwie dieses set gehabt.
Du set.
So als Komma.
Oh.
Nicht dat.
Okay.
Sehr gut.
Und jetzt in das echo.
Echo line.
Okay.
Alles klar.
Das ist schon mal ganz gut.
Jetzt haben wir hier vorne die Anzahl stehen.
Machen wir noch ein echo.
Minus n.
Äh.
Ne.
Ach da ist immer eine new line hinten dran.
Das macht es jetzt.
Auch nicht grad schöner.
Okay.
Jetzt haben wir es doch hier stehen.
Und jetzt sagen wir mal.
Crap minus v.
Startet nicht mit 13.
Jetzt haben wir den.
Wir machen das anders.
Wir machen.
Das ist eklig man.
Jetzt minus n.
Hä?
Ist es jetzt.
Ach so.
Ähm.
Was ist denn das?
Warum sind hier komische Sonderzeichen drin?
Und warum steht die 13.
Hinten.
Anstatt vorne.
Was?
Was ist jetzt mit dem Ding los?
Okay.
13 ist hinten.
Das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Okay.
Das erste war schon richtig.
Was ich gemacht habe.
Was ich nicht verstehe ist.
Wo kommt.
Ach hier.
Ach hier vom awk kommt das.
Hier.
Ähm.
Wie ging das jetzt nochmal?
Tr.
Das ist schon besser.
Das sieht doch schon mal deutlich besser aus.
So minus n.
Oh.
Was jetzt?
Die 20 Minuten sind noch im Leben.
Noch nicht um.
Jetzt kann ich das nicht mehr raus kopieren.
Oh man.
Die 20 Minuten waren noch im Leben.
Noch nicht um.
Warum ist das jetzt zu gegangen?
Habe ich Quota exited oder was?
Kann ich das wieder neu öffnen?
Okay nice.
So minus n.
Okay.
Äh.
Ich brauche noch ein.
R Zeichen.
Ich habe einen Timer.
Echt wo?
Wo ist ein Timer?
Ach du meinst meinen hier oben.
Ja den habe ich ja nicht gestartet.
Ja das ist jetzt schon besser.
Okay also.
Hier ich copy paste mir das mal.
Falls es abkackt.
Also.
Wir haben.
Zwei Zeilen mit 12.
Und der Rest mit 13.
Hatten wir nicht eben.
Vorhin was mit.
Hier.
Eine Zeile hat nur 12.
Hatten wir nicht vorher was gefunden.
Das es angeblich.
Hier fehlt tatsächlich ein.
Hier fehlt ein Komma.
Aber das haben wir vorhin schon ausprobiert.
Das war auf jeden Fall nicht.
Was sollte man nochmal reinschreiben.
In die Lösungsdatei.
Ja.
Elektro District Name.
Also das habe ich vorhin ausprobiert.
Das war auf jeden Fall.
Nicht das richtige.
Was hier auch heißen würde.
Wir haben.
Was ist denn da. Was ist denn da oben drin.
Was ist denn das.
Ähm.
Set no wrap.
Was haben wir denn hier.
Was davon ist denn jetzt das Vote.
Valid.
Percentage of was.
Alter.
Diese drecks Franzosen Kacke man.
Da blickst du und das da brauchen wir.
Rejected ballots.
Und das war Feld 8.
Was haben wir dann noch.
Rejected.
Kommt danach noch irgendwas anderes.
Zahlenmäßiges.
Rejected ballots.
Aber das war ja nicht die Lösung.
Also im Prinzip.
Also eigentlich ist diese Zeile noch scheiß egal.
Da fehlt halt ein Komma.
Und wen juckt.
Also das ist auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Nicht das.
Nicht das Richtige.
Das haben wir schon ausprobiert.
Das war es auf jeden Fall nicht.
Aber sonst ist da kein Fehler drin.
Ja okay.
Wir können alle Namen.
Aber das ist ja wirklich beschiss oder.
Wenn wir alle Namen MD5 summen.
Minus N.
Alter muss.
Ich meine das können wir machen ne.
Ich kann mich nicht mal konzentrieren.
Also ich meine.
Das wäre.
Aber was ich sehr merkwürdig finde.
Wir hatten doch vorhin als wir das hier gemacht haben.
Auf die Datei.
Haben wir doch raus bekommen.
Das ist mehrere.
Ne es gibt nur eine.
Es gibt zwei.
Es gibt zwei Dateien mit zwölf.
Okay.
Dieses Ding.
Set Maus gleich.
Dieses Ding hier ist.
Brocken.
Fix es jetzt trotzdem mal.
Oh shit.
War nicht das was Brocken ist.
Das da.
Die Zeile brauchen wir.
Konnte man nicht E drücken.
Ah ne ich bin schon im Wimp drin.
Ne die will ich doch garnicht hin.
Hä.
Kann die Suche mal gescheit funktionieren.
What the fuck.
Ja das da.
Okay.
In Zeile 101.
Ah das bringt doch garnichts.
Jetzt habe ich das gefixt.
Und weiter.
Okay und jetzt.
Jetzt kann man das wirklich.
Äh Cut.
Minus D.
Feld 2.
Das brauchen wir.
Vor.
Vor I in.
Geht das jetzt an der Stelle.
Hoffe das ist jetzt Funster.
Oder hat der wieder.
EFS Probleme.
Ah man alter.
Wie ging das nochmal.
War das nicht einfach EFS nur auf Dings.
Äh.
Das will ich merken ja.
EFS.
Gleich.
Einfach nur das man sagt.
Oh mein Gott.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal.
Vor EFS Bash.
Aha.
So muss man das also machen.
Stack Overflow. Pogu Time.
Ja sieht schon besser aus.
Okay.
So da sind jetzt Quotes drin.
Die müssen weg.
Seht.
Oh.
Okay.
MD5 Summe.
So und welche MD5 Summe brauchen wir.
Gap.
E399.
Ha.
Nice.
Sehr schön.
Jetzt haben wir es.
Ähm.
Sekunde.
Ich bin verwirrt.
Minus N.
Okay.
Montcalm.
Oh fuck.
Aber wir haben die Lösung.
Montcalm brauchen wir.
Jetzt muss ich mal gucken.
Ob es stimmt.
Wobei.
Ich weiß gar nicht ob es so sehr beschissen ist.
Ich mein wir mussten.
Dass es funktioniert.
Muss man die CSV Datei fixen.
Wobei eigentlich nicht wirklich oder?
Warten wir mal bis das Ding wieder da ist.
Fuba.
Meine Güte.
Es ist gut.
Du musst nicht alles 50 Mal posten.
Ja ich mach noch die SQL Variante.
gucken ob das stimmt. Christian, danke für den Sub. Wetten die Leute haben in dem Test
da auch beschissen? Oh, Popmusik. Auf, 4M, komm bei. Wie ist das Ding? Montka, das passt,
der Name ist so kurz, das ist so ein typischer, typische Lösungsantwort. Öffnen. Oh nein,
es fliegt. Wir müssen es gleich ausschalten, Leute. MySolution. Wie heißt das Ding? Montka.
Okay, das war eine Möglichkeit das rauszukriegen. Wenn auch wohlgemerkt eigentlich schon ein
bisschen beschissen. Ich glaube wir müssen es nochmal neu starten jetzt, oder? Weil er
das automatisch ausschaltet, nachdem wir da durch sind. So, jetzt probieren wir mal
das aus von Fuba und dann probieren wir die SQL-Lösung aus. Ist das ein Rätsel? Ja.
Also man könnte sagen wir haben das Rätsel gelöst, vielleicht auf nicht so ganz faire
Art und Weise, aber meine Geschichte, ich will es nur mit Shell-Tools lösen, weiß
ich nicht, ob das so die beste war. Ich glaube der Ansatz war, ich glaube mein erster Ansatz
war gar nicht verkehrt. Ich bin nur komplett durcheinander gekommen, gekommen in den Feldern
am Ende. Ich habe einfach das Falsche genommen für diese Vote-Geschichte hier. Rejected
Votes. Aber kaputte CSV ist auch schon eine fiese Sache. Ich habe es mir gemerkt,
Zeile 101 ist kaputt. Beides wahrscheinlich gar keinen großen Unterschied macht. Es macht nur
einen Unterschied, wenn ich es importieren will in die Datenbank, dann macht es einen Unterschied.
Okay, so, was habe ich hier jetzt? Ich habe Feld 4 bis 9, nee Feld 4 und 9,
Delimiter, Dings und jetzt habe ich, was bin ich sehend jetzt? Ich meine für das,
dass das angeblich jetzt die komplette Lösung dafür ist. Jetzt hast du alles unter 100.000.
Ja gut, das hatte ich ja vorher in meiner Datei auch. Und jetzt? Achso, ich habe die Votes,
ich habe die Rejected Votes und da machen wir das nochmal in Sort durch. Alles unter 100.000
und jetzt müssen wir uns hinten, genau, jetzt müssen wir uns hinten den Kram rausholen. Genau,
am Feld 2, nee Feld 1, Moment. Ach nee, muss sein. Feld 2. Das sind die kaputten Votes. Ich
könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass man damit sogar schon relativ weit kommt. Ja, guck mal. Es gibt
nur einen, wo diese Votanzahl vorkommt. Ja, das ist natürlich auch nicht verkehrt. Okay,
so hätte es auch funktioniert. Die Votanzahl kommt nur einmal vor, also die Anzahl an ungültigen
Votes. Ja, gut. So und jetzt, und jetzt das Ganze, wir fixen das mal in Zeile 101. Ja,
das ist kaputt. Und jetzt mit der Datenbank. Wie ging das? Moment, importieren. Moment,
import. Ja, das machen wir jetzt. Da bin ich mal gespannt. SQLite. Wie funzt das? Das ist ja jetzt
Bonus. Wie? SQLite 3. Ach Moment, wir müssen noch eine Datei angeben. SQLite keckel.db.
Okay, so. Hat da nicht irgendwie was Kurzes? Ja. Mode csv. Das habe ich noch nie gemacht. Mode
csv. Import. Moment, Moment, ich habe da noch gar keine Tabelle angelegt. Tadingsbums irgendwas
csv. Your table. Okay. Und das hat jetzt funktioniert. Seriously? keckel.db. Okay.
Na dann. Kann man da sowas wie machen? Sie select Sternchen from your table. Tatsächlich. Ha,
lustig. Das, das habe ich noch nie gemacht. csv in SQLite importiert. So über Commandline. Okay,
Chat. Jetzt brauche ich eure five header SQL Kenntnisse. Weil wenn ich von was wirklich
gar keine Ahnung habe, dann sind es SQL Queries. Also wir wollen select. Wir wollen auf jeden Fall
schon mal nicht Sternchen. Was sind die Column Names? Column? Konnte man sich das nicht so mit
Punkt irgendwie anzeigen lassen oder so? Die Column Names sind. Wie lässt man sich das an?
Hier, da ist doch percentage. Steht doch sogar schon da hier. Ja, das sind zum Beispiel Columns.
Select. Da sieht man es doch hier. Also wir wollen im Prinzip, wir wollen einmal, das steht ja hier
in der. Wir wollen einmal haben, den Electoral District, Electoral, Electoral District Name? Nee,
ach. Muss man das quoten in SQLite? Nee. Electoral District? Nee, das macht es,
das macht es ja komplett. Muss man, das muss man doch quoten, oder? Das muss man bestimmt
quoten. Oh man, das Copy Paste funzt hier drin nicht richtig. Also wir wollen das selecten,
oder? Nur, dass ich das jetzt richtig tagge. Wir sollen das finden, dass die largest number
of rejected. Okay, SQL. Okay, wir machen, wir machen erst mal eine Population. Okay,
also where? Population. Kann man das einfach so machen? Kleiner oder größer? Less. Kleiner
hunderttausend ist? Nee. Oh shit. Ja, Chat-Gym. No such Column. Aber Autocomplete macht es. Was
fehlt? Ah, select from. From, ja. My table. Nee, wie ist das Ding? Your table, nicht my table.
Okay, das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert. Das ist bestimmt nicht gültig. Muss man,
muss man da vielleicht less than oder sowas machen? Okay. Shit, mein Datenbank-Zeug,
Alter. Okay, äh, what? Äh, Chat-Gym. Warum kommt da jetzt kein Name raus,
sondern nur der Titel, nur der Titel davon? Nee, ich muss das einfach nur anders quoten.
Where? Das ist bestimmt ein String, ja. Where Population. So, das funzt nicht,
weil das kein, ja, das funzt nicht, weil das kein Int ist. Kann man SQLite sagen,
dass er das irgendwie gefälligst als Int interpretieren soll? SQLite, String to Int,
Form where? Wie, ich habe davon überhaupt keinen Plan. Cast. Okay, cast. Use cast. Gibt es da
ein Exempel für Datenbank-Noobs wie mich? Wie, wie funzt das jetzt? Use as cast. Okay,
also use. Jetzt hier cast, population, as, nee, wie war das? As, as Integer. Hey,
es funktioniert, Leute. Pogu. Mein Datenbank-Lehrer hat das immer Integer ausgesprochen. Der war eh
weird, weird champ. So, da haben wir das doch. So, wo das kleiner als 100.000 ist und was war
noch die andere Einschränkung? Und jetzt, ah, Moment, jetzt muss ich sorten. Jetzt muss ich
sorten. Sort wo? Largest number of, okay, keine Ahnung. Datenbank. Sort by. Sort? Ich habe keine
Ahnung. Order? Ja, Moment. Order by? Order by? Rejected? Rejected? Ah, und jetzt? Desk? Oder
ask? Leute, das ist aber beides falsch. Die Antwort ist aber falsch. Es muss Mount Hill oder sowas
sein. Es sind 100.000. Ach, die sorten wieder auf String-Basis. Ah, ja. Okay, also muss ich jetzt
wieder sagen. Order by, cast, die Musik dabei. As, Int. Ah, hier haben wir es. Leute, Mount Calm.
Das ist es. Okay, das ist die SQL-Lösung. Also ohne Scheiß, da wäre ich noch schlechter drauf
gekommen als auf die andere. Was jetzt? Top? Ne, wie geht das? Oder Limit? Limit. Limit 1? Ne. So?
Oh, meine Datenbank-Skills, Alter. Massive Datenbank-Skills. Was ein Krampf, Mann. Das war
echt schwer. Aber es ist cool. Ich meine, es ist blöd, dass alles so easy ist die letzten Mal. Das
gefällt mir heute schon besser. Was willst du denn machen? Nichts. Fertig. Ich wollte das hier raus
finden. Wir können, wir können jetzt nochmal. Okay, wir können das jetzt nochmal. My Solution,
X-Solution, Mount Calm und sagen Check my Solution. Bam, ist korrekt. 12 Minuten. Oh. Nein, das
ist schlecht. Hab ich gerade beim Verschieben meinen Browser gecrasht? Kann das sein? Ja,
ich hab meinen Browser gecrasht. Nice. Excellent. Boah, Leute, ich kann kein weiteres. Das müssen
wir im nächsten Stream machen. Das reicht mir für heute. Also, was haben wir denn jetzt gemacht?
Wir haben die hier durch. Also, die war easy. Also, das war wirklich, das war too easy. Lustig
übrigens, dass die alle den gleichen Schwierigkeitsgrad haben wie Mr. Jason. Also,
wenn das jetzt schon mittlerweile Medium ist, dann bin ich ja mal auf die neuen schweren
Dinger gespannt. Übrigens, das ist auch New, auch wenn er nicht bei New steht. Ja,
ja, ja, gleiches Bett. Und morgen, wisst ihr, morgen wird angeblich halbwegs, zumindest ab
Mittag, halbwegs gescheites Wetter. Da muss ich ein bisschen Fahrrad fahren. Wird Zeit. Also,
das nächste Mal, nächstes Mal wird es kompliziert. Wenn das schon Medium war,
das nächste Mal gucken wir uns die zwei noch an. Haben wir sogar ein bisschen mehr Zeit für. Och
nee, ich weiß nicht. Wie sieht es, wie sieht es denn da mit Steam? Steam. Schatz. Okay,
ich spiele tatsächlich mega viele Leute. Was ist da? Keck Wait, Alter. Da sollten wir vielleicht
wirklich mal wieder reingucken. So, jetzt muss ich mal kurz schauen. Habe ich irgendwas im Chat
übersehen? Ich habe ja nicht wirklich reingeguckt in letzter Zeit. Ausführlich. Gibt es eine
Extension mit Namen? Kann, nee. Kann Vias Code direkt auf FTP zugreifen und Files hochladen? Also
direkt Build-in? Keine Ahnung. Aber, wobei, ob es der Remote Explorer kann, weiß ich gar nicht.
Nee, kenne ich, kenne ich keiner. Aber ganz ehrlich, in dem Fall ist wahrscheinlich Google
besser als den Twitch-Chat-Fragen. Ja. Erste, was man findet. Okay, anscheinend selbst kannst
du es nicht. Aber es gibt wohl Extensions. Über SSH ist einfacher. Na gut, der Anwendungsfall ist
jetzt ja erstmal ein bisschen unterschiedlich. Bei dem einen wollen sie nur Dateien hochladen,
bei SSH will es sein Server-Remote administrieren, wenn auch man über SSH Dateien kopieren kann. Aber
das wollen die meisten Leute ja dann so nicht machen. Ich weiß eh nicht, warum man heute FTP
benutzt. Warum benutzt man noch FTP? Wahrscheinlich, weil man bei irgendeinem billig Web-Poster ist,
wo man keinen vollständigen VM hat, sondern nur irgendeinen Web-Space, wo man was hochschieben
kann. Oder? Warum? Luko, warum brauchst du noch FTP? Eigentlich irgendein Billig-Poster.
Plask-Hosting. Ja, dann hast du keine VM, sondern nur irgendwo Web-Space. So, ich glaube. Ansonsten
war hier gar nichts mehr im Chat. So, zumindest nichts, was ich noch gesehen hätte. Aber schön,
dass ihr alle so mitgemacht habt. Nächstes Mal geht es weiter. Nächstes Mal kommen die zwei
schweren. Mir reicht es für heute auch echt. Wir haben jetzt noch 20 Minuten Zeit. Chat-GPT,
noch mal irgendwas Spannendes. Moment, Chat-GPT hat jetzt endlich ihre Bilderkennung drin. Sehe ich
das richtig? Interpretiere ich den Titel richtig? Weil ich wollte schon lange mal. Ich habe so ein
Thermostat im Keller. Von dem mache ich öfters mal Bilder. Also was ist Bilder? Ich habe eine
Kamera drauf gerichtet. Die wollte ich schon lange mal AI auswerten lassen. Und ich habe noch keine
AI gefunden, die das gescheit hinbekommt. Wobei es kein Thermostat ist. Das stimmt nicht. Das
ist eine Druckanzeige für die Heizung. Und damit kommt bisher nichts, was ich automatisch zum
Auslesen versucht habe, irgendwie hin. Hier, Heizung, Druckanzeige. Ach, geht nur Bilder
erstellen. Ja, das ist dumm. Guckt, sowas, so ähnlich sieht das aus. Und ich habe, legit,
ich habe noch keine AI und noch keine Bilderkennung gefunden, die das kann. So,
circa so sieht mein Manometer aus. Ich habe noch keine AI und Bilderkennung gefunden,
die das ablesen kann. Zumal man auch sagen muss, mein Kamerabild ist zwar okay, aber nicht Full
HD, nur die Kamera drauf. Also nur das Ding drauf. Ja, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob ich
irgendwas selbst bauen soll. Das dürfte wahrscheinlich am einfachsten sein. Wir haben
mit OpenCV auch schon Dinger gemacht. Das wäre theoretisch möglich. Man könnte, man könnte es
sogar ganz billig machen, indem ich einfach gucke, also noch nicht mal mit OpenCV, sondern irgendwie
einfach gucke hier, wo im Bereich irgendwie ein paar Pixel welche Farbe haben. Aber ich dachte,
es gibt vielleicht irgendwas, wo ich nicht selbst was bauen muss. Du kannst davon ausgehen, wenn es
was gibt, ist das das Erste, was die Leute damit probieren. Das ist Standard, egal was es ist. Auch
VR. Das ist eines der ersten Anwendungsfälle, wofür VR verbreitet war, weil Leute, die sich Porn
angucken wollen damit. Und ich glaube, ich glaube Videokassetten damals auch. Und DVDs glaube ich
auch. Was verdient ein Manager im Recruiting? Oh je, oh je. Das habe ich auch gelesen vorhin,
dass City Skylines oder Skylines 2, dass die ziemliche Probleme haben beim Release. Ja,
jetzt ist ja mal langsam gut, Alter. Jetzt hat er schon irgendwie irgendwelche Shorts mit Ausschnitt
vorne. Das nimmt echt so Comedy Gruppe Vibes an. Working harder will not make you richer. Das
kann man so pauschal wahrscheinlich nicht sagen. Wahrscheinlich ist das Fazit aus dem Video, man
muss es schlau machen. Man muss es schlau machen und schlau in Kombination mit sich noch richtig
reinhängen. Ja, dann vielleicht, aber da bin ich viel zu faul für. Ob man eine Bib nutzen kann,
für Uhrzeiterkennung gut ist und diese etwas um... Das weiß ich nicht. Das ist eine gute Frage. Das
müssen wir mal ausprobieren. Aber meistens ist es ein größerer Akt rauszubekommen, wie die
Bilderkennung funktioniert, um das umzubauen, als irgendwie selbst was anderes zu stricken.
Übrigens bei Bib, ich bin mittlerweile schon echt ein bisschen pipiger. Das erste, woran ich bei Bib
gedacht habe, sind Fahrradhosen. Es gibt Fahrradhosen mit so... Ja, dann sieht man automatisch so aus,
sobald man die Dinger anhat. Mit... Das eigentliche ist... Das eigentlich Spannende da drin ist das
Polster. Das Polster, was da drin ist, wo es jetzt irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen keine
Bilder von gibt. Da gibt's... Da gibt's Polster drin, dass einem der Arsch nicht so wehtut. Ja,
so ein bisschen wie das hier oben sieht es aus. Und das ist echt praktisch, weil sonst gatschi
Bobbes schmerzen, wenn man ohne Bib Hose fährt. Man gewöhnt sich aber echt schnell dran. Also
die ersten Male, wo ich gefahren bin, jetzt als ich das neu gekauft habe, hat mir echter Bobbes
wehgetan. Aber ich bin dann... Ich bin letztes Wochenende... Ich bin am... Bin mir nicht ganz
sicher. Am Samstag oder am Sonntag, ich habe euch das Video davon gezeigt, bin ich 37 Kilometer hier
ein bisschen rum gefahren und dann einen Tag später bin ich nach Frankfurt und zurück 54
Kilometer gefahren so. Quasi ohne... Ohne groß Pause dazwischen und der Arsch hat nicht wehgetan.
Also insofern scheint man sich wirklich dran zu gewöhnen. Alles... Alles eine Übungs... Übungssache.
This is why you don't outsource your network security. In this video I discussed Cisco
Critical Vulnerability, a CFO that has been used to take... Oh! Gut, dass ich keine Cisco-Dinger
irgendwie erreichbar habe. Keck. Was... Was... Was umfasst das? Was umfasst das denn? Oh, ich habe
glaube ich hier die Hälfte. Was umfasst das denn? Okay, da gibt es noch nichts offizielles zu. Mit
genaueren Details hat Heise was dazu geschrieben. Hier. Schwere Sicherheitslücke in iOS XE. Übrigens
wusstet ihr, dass die... Wer hätte das gedacht? Dass die auch Probleme mit Apple hatten. Das...
Apple hatte aber das Problem, dass sie später waren. Das Ding hieß schon iOS lange bevor es
Apple iOS gab und ich bilde mir ein, dass vor Jahren, die einen Deal gemacht haben mit Cisco
damals, dass Apple das iOS benutzen darf. Also das hieß... Das heißt schon ewig iOS. Lange,
bevor es iPhones gab. Geräte mit Cisco. Ist das das x86? Diese x86 halb, halb Linux, halbe,
halbe Cisco-Firmware? Oder was ist XE? Ach, es ist ein Release Train. MonkaDB. Ah, sag ich doch!
Das ist das... Das ist das Cisco-Linux-Ding. Irgendwie hatte ich das dann doch noch im
Hinterkopf. Sag ich doch. Geräte mit iOS XE und WebUI können von Angreifern... Ja,
deswegen ist Zugriff auf Netzwerk-Config-Interfaces immer doof. Von unberechtigten Stellen,
wo das möglich ist. Deswegen haben auch alle, die ein bisschen was über ihre Netzwerk-Security
halten, nicht einfach random ein Web-Interface an, irgendwo in einem Public... Public schon mal
gar nicht. In einem Netzwerk, wo Leute drauf zugreifen können, sondern haben extra Management-Ports.
Und das Web-Interface ist aus. Niemand ernsthaft, den ich kenne, der sich auch nur ein bisschen
professionell mit Netzwerk-Hardware beschäftigt, benutzt zum massenhaft Konfigurieren von
Switchen irgendwie Web-Interfaces. Das ist wunderbar für daheim. Ja, das ist wunderbar,
wenn man 1, 2, 3, 4, 5 vielleicht Netzwerk-Geräte hat. Aber nicht, weil man 500 hat und die vielleicht
auch einigermaßen eindeutig konfigurieren. Also ich kenne wirklich niemand. Kennt ihr
irgendjemand, der im Business oder sagen wir mal im... Muss ja nicht super krass Business
Enterprise sein. Also im professionellen Umfeld das Disco-Web-Interface zum Konfigurieren von
Geräten benutzt? Also mir fällt keiner ein. Aber vielleicht ist ja das iOSXE-Web-Interface
so richtig geil, dass du es dann benutzt. Ja, und wenn man das Web-UI übers Internet
dranhängt, ist man ja eh komplett lost. Ja, Ansible habe ich schon öfters gehört, dass
Netzwerk-Admins das gerne verwenden. Das war mir bis vor kurzem gar nicht so klar, dass das da so
beliebt ist. Das ist hauptsächlich im Linux-Bereich. Aber ja, Netzwerk ergibt ja auch Sinn.
ISE habe ich schon mal gehört. Ist ISE nicht die Firewall-Geschichte? Also um Firewall-Regeln
zu machen und so, da lasse ich mir ein Web-Interface gefallen. Aber wir reden ja hier von so Sachen wie
welche Ports sollen hochgefahren sein, welche WLAN-Tags kommen drauf und solche Geschichten.
Das macht doch niemand über das Web-Interface. AZA ist die Firewall. Aber AZA ist auch die alte
Firewall, die es nicht mehr gibt, oder? Heißt das jetzt nicht anders? Oder ist AZA das Neue und
ich bringe es durcheinander? Aber einfach mal ernsthaft. Also ich sehe ein, dass das super
kritisch ist. Und dass das eine hohe Stellnummer bekommt, verstehe ich auch. Aber ernsthaft. Also
wer sowas, wer das Config-Web-Interface von seinem Netzwerkgerät public ins Internet hängt,
ohne irgendwas davor. Also das ist schon ziemlich lost. CLI wird auf lange Sicht immer weniger.
Ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, wie man das ordentlich konfigurieren soll ohne CLI. Aber gut,
vielleicht gibt es da ja was. Ich kenne niemand, der Cisco Web-Interface benutzt in dem Umfeld. Ich
frage mich auch, wie das gehen soll. Meraki ist glaube ich auch von Cisco. Also ich verstehe das,
weil man halt nur ein paar Geräte hat. Aber wenn man jetzt sagen wir mal, da sicherstellen will,
dass Geräte, also jedes Gerät hat den gleichen Admin-User drauf. Jedes Gerät hat die gleichen
WLAN-Sachen konfiguriert. Die gleichen OSPF-Geschichten und sowas. Wenn man das einheitlich
machen will, wenn man ein neues Netzwerkgerät bekommt, das kann man doch nicht übers Web-Interface
machen. Da drehst du doch komplett am Rad, oder? Über Curl das Web-Interface. Das ist es, Chat.
Nicht über Curl. Wie heißt das neue Ding, was jetzt alle verwenden? Früher war es Selenium,
dann war es Puppeteer und wie heißt das? Playwright heißt das jetzt. Was die coolen
Leute jetzt verwenden. Bei Playwright wird das gescriptet. Ja, das ist ziemlich MonkaS,
wenn man ohne jegliche Authentifizierung Root-Rechte auf dem Gerät hat. Aber ich
finde es trotzdem extrem lost, Web-Interface, also Config-Web-Interface des Public ins Internet
zu stellen. Wobei es ja nicht nur Public im Internet betrifft, sondern es ist ja auch,
selbst wenn es nicht Public im Internet ist, solange es in irgendeinem Netzwerk hängt,
wo sagen wir mal auch vielleicht über Umwege Unautorisierte dran kommen,
zum Beispiel ein Gast-WLAN oder sowas, dann ist es natürlich auch pippiger. Deswegen Web-Interface
oder generell, wenn Remote-Administration im größeren Stil, dann nur mit eigenem Admin-Netz.
Bietet sich bei den Cisco-Dingern auch an. Oder so wie das Niko letztens gemacht hat im Video,
direkt ein paar Konsolenkabel dran. Wie 2008 noch. Ich kann mich noch an die Cisco erinnern,
das waren blaue Kabel immer. Die Cisco-Konsolenkabel sind immer so blaue Dinge und die haben auf der
einen Seite einen RJ45-Stecker und auf der anderen, oder war es umgedreht? Warte mal.
Ne, die haben auf der einen Seite einen RJ45-Stecker und auf der anderen USB? Oh,
ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. So ein blaues Kabel ist das auf jeden Fall, ja. Haben die noch Seriell?
Stimmt! Ja, ja, ja, ja, klar. Die haben noch Seriell. Wir hatten immer einen USB auf Serial-Adapter
und haben dann Minicom auf dem Notebook aufgemacht. Ne, das sind schon die... Ja,
hier die da, die. Das sind sie, genau. Die kenne ich, aber die Farbe ist komisch fotografiert.
Vom Gefühl her habe ich eher die Farbe im Gedächtnis behalten als die Farbe. Aber es
ist schon eine ganze Weile her, ehrlich. Das Dunklere ist das Neue, okay. Also es ist wirklich
schon ganz lange her, wo ich das gemacht habe. Das letzte Mal, wo ich an der Cisco-Kiste,
also dort, wo es auch, sagen wir mal, um was ging, wo das auch ein richtig echtes Live-Netzwerk-Gerät
noch gewesen ist. Das letzte Mal, wo ich per serieller Konsole an den Cisco-Switch gegangen
bin. Das war wahrscheinlich, also ich denke mal nicht nach 2011. Also schon zwölf Jahre her.
Also sagen wir mal so, vor 2012, relativ sicher, war das. Ja, ja, dass man das lernt und so ist
auch vollkommen okay. Aber ich habe damit halt einfach nichts mehr zu tun. Wahrscheinlich kann
man das heute noch machen, ja? Ich habe damit einfach nichts mehr zu tun seit spätestens 2012,
was Netzwerk-Hardware anging. Und ich weiß noch, dass man damals genau darauf achten musste,
was man in Minicom bei der seriellen Schnittstelle eingestellt hat. Also quasi,
welche Baudrate. Ich glaube, was war Default? 33? 33k? Oder 115k? Ich weiß gar nicht, was das
Default war. Ich meine, es war mehr als 9,6k. Da musste man auch die richtige Decoding,
Encoding einstellen. Irgendwelche, irgendwelche Skip-Bits und Zeug. Wenn man da nicht magic,
Art und Weise mal eine Config von einem bekommen hat, der das schon eingerichtet hat,
warst du lost. Da hast du erstmal 45 Minuten mit dem Laptop rumgestanden, bis du es wieder
eingerichtet hast. Ja, das war wirklich ganz wilde Dinger noch. Ja. Es ist ein Vorteil,
wenn man ein bisschen älter ist. Da kann man ab und zu ein paar Boomer-Stories erzählen. Die
Story von dem ehemaligen Kollege, der in der Kantine einen Schnitzel geklaut hat,
habe ich euch schon erzählt, ja? Da könnte ich einfach mal ein Video, ich glaube, da mache ich
ein Video drüber. Ich finde die Story immer witzig. Ich glaube, da nehme ich morgen mal ein
Video zu auf. Ja, habe ich euch, glaube ich, schon erzählt. Da nehme ich mal ein Video zu
auf. Ja, wir hatten mal einen Kollege, der einen Schnitzel geklaut hat in der Kantine. Und ich
weiß bis heute nicht, warum. Ich glaube, das war einfach so eine, weil es geht, guck mal her,
ich habe es hingekriegt, nochmal. Ich habe seit 45 Tagen kein Video mehr hochgeladen. Wird echt
mal wieder Zeit. Edel-Switcher habe ich auch nie gehabt. Also Netzwerk-Equipment kenne ich
tatsächlich nur, also Enterprise-Netzwerk-Equipment, kenne ich tatsächlich auch nur die Cisco-Kisten
von früher. Und ja gut, mein MikroTik daheim zählt natürlich nicht. Und daheim ist ja auch
kein Business. Ja, ich weiß. Das mache ich tatsächlich. Das mache ich auf jeden Fall. Ich
habe gesagt, dass es als nächstes Video kommt, aber wenn ich morgen ab 11 Uhr nochmal irgendwie
drei Stunden Fahrrad fahren bin, das wird nichts da ein bisschen was Größeres aufzunehmen. Aber
mal kurz irgendwie so eine 12-13 Minuten Story plus ein bisschen Gelaber drumherum, dass das
funktioniert. Das Face-Reveal-Video bei einer Million ist safe. Ich werde halt nie eine Million
erreichen, aber also nicht in absehbarer Zeit zumindest. Ich tippe mal eher auf nie und dann
mache ich den Face-Reveal. Ja, ja. Die Bots werden eh direkt wieder entfernt. Macht keinen Scheiß,
Leute. Also wie gesagt, ich hatte weder HP noch Dell-Switcher bisher im Enterprise-Umfeld. Ich
hatte da nur Cisco-Kisten früher. Und doch nicht ganz, stimmt nicht ganz. Wir hatten noch,
ich glaube IBM-Fiber-Channel-Switcher. Gibt es Fiber? Sagt euch irgendein Fiber-Channel-Hersteller
Procade oder sowas? Die gibt es, oder? Ich habe das noch im Hinterkopf, dass das irgendwelche
IBM, war das von IBM? Procade oder so. Procade-Switche gab, ja. Fiber-Channel. Ja, genau solche
Dinger. Die kosteten teilweise, also ob das jetzt exakt das war, weiß ich nicht. Aber solche Plate-Einschübe
und für Plate-Sender war das, die haben teilweise neu über 10.000 Euro gekostet. Jetzt ist schön
billig. Das kostet 48 Euro das Stück. Na gut, wer will auch Plate-Sender einfach so betreiben. Die
kosteten teilweise neu über 10.000 Euro und als die bei uns ausgemustert wurden, haben wir die
dann als Türstopper verwendet. Da hatten wir wahrscheinlich kurzzeitig, gut mittlerweile bei
48 Euro nicht mehr, aber da hatten wir wahrscheinlich kurzzeitig einen der teuersten Türstopper der
Welt. Ich glaube die wenigsten haben 10.000 Euro Türstopper. Die gehören jetzt zu Extreme Networks.
Aha, da habe ich das richtige Erinnerung gehabt, die gab es mal. Ja, bietet sich auch an. Ich finde
das immer noch, ganz ehrlich, ich finde das eine super Plattform, wo Azubis sich ordentlich austoben
können. Plate-Sender ist ein kompaktes Ding. Du kriegst da viel Hardware rein. Du hast da dann
immer jetzt aktuell die modernste Hardware und sicherlich auch noch die schnellste Hardware
drin. Aber es ist ja nun schon lange so, da frisst Strom ohne Ende. Ja, das interessiert aber doch
meistens gar nicht im Rechenzentrum. Wenn es danach geht, könntest du wahrscheinlich, also
wahrscheinlich könnten die meisten Rechenzentren bestimmt locker ein Drittel ihres Stroms einsparen.
Wenn sie sich mal angucken müssten, brauchen wir die ganzen Kisten eigentlich noch. Ich finde
Plate-Sender ist super, super Sache. Mir persönlich schwebt ja immer noch irgendwann vor, dass ich
mal so einen IBM Plate-Sender auf, sagen wir mal, auf Inline-Skates stelle oder so. Irgendwas mit
leichtgängigen Rollen und dann ein Netzteil rausziehe, weil dann drehen die Lüfter auf 100% und dann
gucken, wie schnell das wird. Das wollte ich schon seit ich Azubi bin ausprobieren. Wie schnell kann
ein Plate-Sender maximal fahren auf ordentlichen Rollen? Rein durch den Lüfter, der da drin ist,
weil das Ding hat brutalste Lüfter drin. Also ich habe bisher nichts erlebt, was am Luftstrom an
einem Plate-Sender auf 100% drankäme. Also im Rechenzentrum, ja. Ich gehe davon aus, eine
Flugzeugturbine und sowas. Das habe ich aber auch noch nicht live dahinter gestanden. Das wird
natürlich mehr sein. Aber ich habe noch keine Hardware gesehen, die einen krasseren Luftflow
hatte als ein Plate-Sender auf 100%. Nicht eingesaugt, weggepustet. Also bei den Plate-Sendern
war das so. Da habe ich mal so ein olles Ding. Ja, genau. Die fette Dinger, diese fetten Teile.
Das sind, glaube ich, 8 HE gewesen. Also Rack Höheneinheiten. Und die haben richtig krass
auf 100% aufgedreht. Und wenn du dahinter gestanden hast, also wenn du im Rack gestanden
hast, hinter dem Server, da wo du immer standest eigentlich, weil dort die Anschlüsse sind. Guck
mal, das hat noch Diskette oben. Also stellt euch vor, das Plate-Sender war im Rack relativ weit
unten und ihr habt dahinter gekniet mit dem Notebook oder so. Oder seid da rumgekrabbelt.
Also wenn ihr da vorgekniet habt, ihr musstet euch bestimmt so 20-30 Grad nach vorne neigen in
der Hocke, dass euch das nicht rückwärts zurückgepustet hat. Wenn ihr natürlich sicher
gestanden habt, dann ist das kein Problem. Also das hat jetzt nicht irgendwie einen 90-Kilo-Max
da weggepustet oder so. Aber das hatte schon echt krassen Airflow, das Ding. Ich habe mir
übrigens für den Fahrradlenker einen neuen Mount gekauft für die GoPro, dass man jetzt die oberen
Zeilen vom Fahrradcomputer sieht und auch links und rechts noch die Griffe vom Lenker. Das ist
ein bisschen spannender zuzugucken. Und vielleicht labere ich ja wieder eine Runde dabei und dann
muss auf jeden Fall bei jeder zweiten Kurve Mon Castille wieder fallen. Ihr erinnert euch ja
vielleicht noch dran. Mon Castille, Mon Castille. Weiß auch nicht. Ich weiß nicht, warum das Erste,
was mir einfällt, wenn es huppelig ist auf dem Weg mit dem Fahrrad Mon Castille ist. Jeder andere
denkt da an, was ein scheiß Weg. Warum ist das hier so wellig? Und mein erster Gedanke war Mon
Castille. Das kann sein. Da habe ich noch nicht hinter einem gesessen, der 100% hat. Ich kenne
die etwas älteren Core-Switche von Cisco. Die haben ja so verschiedene Sachen. Tier 1, Tier 2,
Tier 3 oder irgendwie sowas. Oder Layer 1. Die haben ja so verschiedene Größen. Catalyst
heißen die Dinger doch von Cisco, oder? Diese Reihe dafür. Und die gibt es in verschiedenen
großen Bauweisen. Da war ich sogar schon dran mal, aber ich habe den noch nie erlebt bei 100%.
Ich durfte, an die durfte ich auch nie dran früher. Weil das war nicht in unserem Aufgabenbereich,
das super teure Netzwerkequipment. Wir waren für Lenungskisten zuständig, hatten mit Cisco wenig
am Hut. Und da wollten die Netzwerkleute nicht, dass irgendjemand drangeht, der keine Ahnung hat.
Was ich auch verstehen kann. Ich habe mir den Titel gespeichert. Da machen wir am Wochenende
weiter. Gag Wait. Leute, warum sagt mir keiner Bescheid? Was ist denn jetzt? Jetzt habe ich
10 Minuten zu wenig Schlaf. Das bin ich morgen überhaupt nicht fit. Schon, schon spät. Mamonkas
Tier im Bett. Genau. Okay. Chat, wir hören uns. War schön, dass ihr da wart. Hello Terra. Ich
bin jetzt weg. Bis denn, CU.